[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7 8
c'est votre émission pour bien démarrer
la soirée dans les Yvelines avec au menu
de l'actualité des infos pratiques et
des idées de sortie bonsoir Mathieu
bonsoir Céline bonsoir Gabriel ça va en
plateau Mathilde
Paris aussi pour pour faire cette
émission et vous Gabriel première pour
vous en plateau Gabriel Gontier qui nous
a rejoint cette saison à TV 78 pas trop
stressé pour ses débuts
avec la visite de Brigitte Macron à
Poissy à l'occasion d'Octobre Rose le
mois de sensibilisation au cancer du
sein la première dame c'est rendu aux
trois arches ce lieu accompagne des
personnes atteintes par le cancer leurs
proches aussi les aidants dans un
instant le témoignage de Christelle
l'une des bénéficiaires
deuxième journée vous allez le voir
aussi pour les Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste c'est jusqu'à
dimanche sauver le drone national de
saint-quentin-en-y mini nous ferons le
point sur les résultats d'hier plutôt
décevant pour les Français rencontrent
également avec Fanny Cauchois on
habitant des Yvelines en lice pour ces
mondiaux avec le Laos
[Musique]
et puis à l'approche du week-end aux
idées de sortie pour ce samedi à 15 et
dimanche 16 octobre dans le département
festival de la BD foire médiévale et
murder party le programme en deuxième
partie d'émission
avec notamment un concert pour l'Ukraine
qui sera donné à dimanche en la
cathédrale à Saint-Louis de Versailles à
l'affiche notamment de ce concert
Georges Schmitt qui est avec nous par
visio conférence bonsoir
alors pour vous présenter vous comptez
16 albums à votre actif plus de 4
millions de disques vendus dans le monde
11 disques d'or et on pouvait aussi on
peut on vous a fait votre connaissance
dans TV sur TV 78 au travers d'un
portrait vous nous expliquez à l'époque
à l'époque que vous fabriquiez vous-même
vos instruments c'est ça je vais
fabriquer toujours j'ai fabriqué
toujours toutes mes flûtes parce que ça
me permet d'avoir la qualité que je
cherche de pouvoir générer accordables
j'ai mis dans chaque tube des pistons
qui fait que je peux pousser ou tirer
les pistons ça me permet de m'accorder
en fonction de des orgues qui
m'accompagne
les 78.com pour retrouver le portrait de
Georges Schmitt et je le disais vous
serez à l'affiche du concert pour
l'Ukraine notamment aux côtés de Francis
Rudy alors de la chorale accorhini pour
ce concert et on en dira plus tout à
l'heure dans cette émission dans un
instant également les informations du
jour Mathilde on parle toujours
d'essence est-ce que vous avez pu vous
êtes sur ce plateau donc j'ai la réponse
vous avez pu venir à tv78 sans
difficulté aujourd'hui au moins la
moitié du plein dans ma voiture j'ai pas
à me plaindre j'habite pas très loin
donc ça va aussi côté essence pour vous
Gabriel j'ai réussi à faire le plein
donc tout va bien
sont mes meilleurs amis donc voilà
s'adapter à adaptation avec
effectivement cette crise du carburant
avec peut-être des améliorations on le
verra dans un instant avec vous Céline
on va parler aussi pollution pollution
lumineuse plus précisément il y a le
jour de la nuit qui va se dérouler ce
week-end
qui se déroulera samedi ce samedi 15
dans les plusieurs villes ivinoises donc
plusieurs activités animations sont à
prévoir effectivement ça parlera de la
pollution lumineuse et j'en ai dit un
mot tout à l'heure Gabriel tout à
l'heure avec vous les idées de sortie du
week-end donnez-nous un peu envie
qu'est-ce que de quoi il sera question
dans ces idées de sortie les sorties à
ne pas manquer ce weekend on parlera de
la BD on parlera d'un festival médiéval
aussi plein de surprises vous
découvrirez ça juste après et ce sera
suivre sur TV 78 mais coup d'œil d'abord
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
malheureusement c'est nuageux pour
toutes les Yvelines dans la matinée de
vendredi côté température 15 degrés à
Versailles Rambouillet et Houdan c'est
14 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie pour
l'après-midi ça s'arrange ou ça empire
selon l'endroit où vous habitez de la
pluie à Houdan et Rambouillet où il fera
respectivement 15 et 16 degrés ce
devrait rester ça devrait rester nuageux
à Versailles avec 15 degrés il y aura
quelques éclaircies tout de même à
Mantes-la-Jolie ce vendredi 14 octobre
nous fêterons les justes
après la météo les informations du jour
je le disais il y a un instant Mathilde
il y a du mieux concernant la grève même
si on est pas totalement tiré d'affaires
quand même oui Grégory alors la grève et
levée à la raffinerie Desseaux et dès
Queen mobile à Fos-sur-Mer dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône mais la situation est
toujours au point mort pour Total
énergie les salariés refusent de
débloquer les expéditions de carburant
tant qu'ils n'auront pas eu l'assurance
des meilleurs salaires hier soir
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé un retour à la
normale dans la semaine sur France 2
mais de son côté la directrice régionale
d'Île-de-France de Total énergie se
montre moins confiante écouter
et on va l'entendre dans quelques
instants
on continue toujours à mettre en oeuvre
ses moyens pour assurer
l'approvisionnement et puis par ailleurs
évidemment il est important de
poursuivre le dialogue social et donc
les organisations syndicales seront
reçues une à une par la direction cet
après-midi pour essayer voilà de trouver
des solutions constructives on a bien
conscience de l'impact pour pour les
Franciliens pour les Français et donc il
y a un lien important de d'essayer de
trouver les solutions
en attendant la situation est toujours
compliquée dans les stations services
comme ce matin à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
vous pouvez le voir sur les images les
policiers devaient faire la circulation
et la grève également mais des bus cette
fois-ci à Poissy et aux Mureaux
aujourd'hui et demain les lignes de bus
Keolis tourneront au ralenti les
salariés dénoncent la dégradation de la
qualité de service et leurs conditions
de travail le détail des perturbations
ligne par ligne sur le site et
l'application deal France mobilité
ponctué par les grèves alors c'était
hier l'Association des Maires des
Hauts-de-Seine l'Union des mers des
Yvelines organisait l'Université des
mairies de l'Ouest parisien 2000
participants pour cet événement c'est au
Port Marly oui Grégory 2000 participants
rendez-vous phare des mers des Yvelines
et des Hauts-de-Seine cet événement
permet aux élus de se rencontrer
d'échanger avec leur partenaires et de
parler de leurs problématiques actuelles
et nous vous en parlons hier lors de
notre édition spéciale nous avons
accompagné deux étudiantes de Sciences
Po Solène Hanifa et Enza benotchi elles
ont demandé au maire la raison de leur
venue on les écoute
poursuivre un petit peu l'évolution de
tout ce qui se passe autour de nous
il faut se tenir au courant il faut
rencontrer certaines personnes
participer aussi à des formations des
formations rapides c'est très important
on va parler sport dans un instant avec
le cyclisme sur piste il est aussi
question de sport pour la fin de ces
informations du jour avec le FC
Versailles qui s'est imposé hier soir
c'était face à Le Mans
le FC Versailles Renaud avec la victoire
il s'est imposé 2 à 1 face au mangue
grâce à une superbe frappe de Djoko à la
22e et un but de prunier à la 27e minute
le FC Versailles fait un bon dans le
classement en se retrouvant sur le
podium à seulement trois petits points
de Concarneau et Dunkerque
Céline hier vous avez parlé d'une
signature inversée vous souvenez du
joueur qui a signé à Versailles la
petite colle comment s'appelle-t-il j'en
ai aucune idée
ancien joueur professionnel et qui est
d'ailleurs passé par le manque qui a
signé à Versailles Versailles qui a
enregistré l'arrivée de nombreux
renforts et d'anciens joueurs
professionnels on peut citer aussi être
jeremenlands pardon pour pour cette
petite
histoire du foot c'est facile peut-être
que vous pourrez me poser une petite
colle tout à l'heure
mais dans l'actualité également Mathilde
il y a Brigitte Macron qui s'est rendu
c'était ce mercredi à Poissy oui elle
est venue rendre visite à la maison les
trois arches de Poissy alors c'est une
structure qui ne n'offre pas de soin
médicaux pour lutter contre le cancer du
sein mais plutôt d'autres soins plus
physiques et psychologiques je vous
propose avec Céline on est allé couvrir
cet événement je vous propose de
regarder le reportage dans le cadre
d'Octobre Rose Brigitte Macron était à
Poissy ce mercredi 12 octobre pour
visiter la maison les trois arches ce
centre d'accompagnement au cancer a pour
objectif de soutenir les patients et les
proches touchés par la maladie depuis
son ouverture en 2021 la maison a
accueilli 110 personnes tous les
patients que j'ai rencontrés me disent
tous que ça va mieux que ça participe
tout à fait aussi à leur guérison donc
il y a aussi une rassurance que le
patient peut avoir parce comprend tous
ces symptômes qu'il a autour de la
maladie ici il ou elle va comprendre ce
qui se passe non seulement il va
comprendre mais il va partager avec
d'autres parce que on ne peut se
comprendre
contre patients constitué de trois pôles
informations soin oncologie et mieux
être la maison les trois arches permet
aux femmes qui souffrent ou ont souffert
du cancer du sein de se retrouver pour
des ateliers on explique aux patient
quels sont les recommandations
nutritionnelles pour éviter les
récidives comment s'alimenter aussi
pendant les traitements par exemple
pendant la chimiothérapie la
radiothérapie il y a beaucoup d'effets
secondaires indésirables de la fatigue
ils ont pas toujours
l'énergie l'envie de se nourrir nous
participons à l'atelier retour un emploi
qui a un cycle de 5 ateliers qui permet
justement aux personnes sous contrat de
travail en arrêt de pouvoir avoir un
espace pour poser toutes leurs questions
leurs interrogations sur le pour en
emploi est-ce que ça va être possible
dans quel dans quelles conditions la
structure permet également aux patient
de se soutenir entre eux on échange avec
sa famille ou des amis qui vous disent
des
traitements sont finis donc tes guéris
pour eux ça y est la maladie est passée
derrière mais on est toujours on a
toujours une épée de Damoclès au-dessus
de la tête la maison les trois arches
accompagne sur le plan physique avec des
ateliers cuisine ou gym adaptés par
exemple et sur le plan psychologique et
social avec des ateliers kinésithérapie
ou sophrologie
vous étiez donc sur place pour ce
reportage et ce qui est quelque chose
que vous souhaitez mettre en avant
quelque chose que vous allez retenu de
ce reportage sur place
des femmes qui ont cancer du sein et en
fait elles n'ont tout dit vraiment ça
leur a permis de pouvoir rencontrer
d'autres femmes qui souffrent de cette
maladie de ce cancer et du coup les ça
les aide en fait de parler elles se
comprennent mieux
rencontre
pluridisciplinaire c'est à dire que ça
touche vraiment tous les aspects or soin
médicaux purement fait à l'hôpital là
c'est complètement ça les accompagne
dans même la réinsertion à l'emploi le
sport savoir prendre soin de soi c'est
vraiment il y a tous les domaines et ça
c'est c'est très agréable pour elle
finalement sur Brigitte Macron même si
elle est la première dame la femme du
président de la République a été plutôt
abordable c'était plutôt facile de lui
poser des questions
très accessible elle a parlé à tout le
monde elle a même fait des petites
blagues non elle était accessible
c'était très émouvant aussi à certains
moments prenaient vraiment le temps de
discuter et d'apprendre à les connaître
aussi vrai que plusieurs femmes du coup
on pleurait suite à sa visite d'émotion
quoi c'était un moment fort peut-être
l'occasion de revenir sur ce déplacement
avec notre invité par visioconférence
c'est Christelle Suchaud bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes habitant d'Andrésy et
vous êtes l'une des bénéficiaires de
cette structure les trois arches vous
avez été décelé d'un cancer du sein en
2020 alors pour revenir déjà sur sur
votre parcours expliquez un petit peu
votre histoire c'est sans doute un
cancer qui a été diagnostiqué avec un an
de retard il y a eu un an de retard sur
la prise en charge parce que dès 2019
vous avez ressenti des symptômes c'est
ça
dès 2019 il y avait des symptômes
effectivement voilà un écoulement
mammaire et qui est assez méconnu
finalement mais pourtant ça fait partie
ça fait partie effectivement des signes
précurseurs d'un cancer du sein j'aurais
du mal à l'armer à ce moment-là et
malheureusement voilà j'ai pas pris soin
de ça pensant que c'est un eczéma tout
simple comme quoi dès qu'on voit une
réaction sur son sein il faut tout de
suite tout de suite tout de suite
alerter effectivement son gynécologue
son médecin traitant parce que voilà
j'ai laissé traîner un an et en 2020
on va diagnostiqué effectivement un
cancer du sein métastatique et ça me
touche d'en parler puisque aujourd'hui
nous sommes le 13 octobre et c'est la
Journée nationale du cancer du sein
métastatique voilà c'est assez méconnu
mais malheureusement comme ça un stade
avancé ça devient l'état statique et là
on peut mettre sur des soins qui vont
être sur plusieurs années au niveau
hospitalier
quatre cancers du sein qui sont détectés
chaque année en France et vous lisiez
c'est important voilà dès les premiers
signes de salarié puisque on sait qu'un
cancer du sein qui est diagnostiqué très
toit a beaucoup plus de chances de
guérir dans dans 9 cas sur 10 alors vous
quand vous avez appris que vous étiez
attendre d'un cancer du sein la réaction
que vous avez eu c'est un sentiment
d'isolement vous êtes plutôt isolé et
vous avez eu du mal à l'accepter c'est
ça j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à accepter
voilà je m'attendais pas du tout à ça en
fait
je franchement non je pour moi c'était
une visite de contrôle même s'il y avait
quelque chose je pensais que c'était
autre chose et quand on a diagnostiqué
qu'on m'a parlé qu'on m'a dit le mot
cancer je me suis vraiment effondrée
vraiment et ça a été très très dur pour
moi oui je me suis isolée je me suis
isolée même du corps médical il fallait
que il fallait que je reprenne confiance
en moi il fallait que je comprenne ce
qui se passe voilà ça a été vraiment un
tremblement de terre pour moi vraiment
alors comment c'est fait le lien avec
les trois arches parce qu'on a bien
compris que l'objectif de cette rupture
de cette structure c'est d'accompagner
les personnes qui sont qui sont malades
comment vous avez connu les trois arches
comment c'est fait le lien justement et
que avec la structure
alors en fait de culpabiliser beaucoup
de pas reprendre le travail la fin de la
chimio et donc j'ai passé des mois et
des mois à ne rien faire à rester sur le
canapé à ne rien faire et ne pas savoir
ce que j'allais faire par la suite parce
que j'étais fatiguée et je n'avais pas
le moral mais je me suis dit bah le seul
moyen c'est de reprendre le travail donc
je suis allé voir mon médecin traitant
pensant pouvoir reprendre le travail et
je me suis effondrée je veux dire en
fait j'en suis pas capable il m'a donné
les coordonnées d'une psychologue
finalement je te dis je ne suis pas
allée voir et par chance le lendemain je
suis allée sur les réseaux sociaux de la
ville de Poissy et j'ai trouvé un
programme sur les trois arches dans le
cadre rose justement voilà l'année
dernière et
je me suis dit waouh c'est ma chance en
fait ça représentait tout ce dont
j'avais besoin à ce moment là donc des
soins des soins sociaux esthétiques pour
réapprendre à se maquiller à reprendre
confiance en moi
il y avait de l'activité physique
adaptée moi qui ne faisait plus rien qui
avait plus d'énergie pour rien voilà
j'ai trouvé ça avec un personnel
encadrant
enfin il y a tellement de choses qui ont
été faites pour moi que je remercierai
jamais assez les trois arches pour ça et
j'ai fait aussi l'atelier de sophrologie
voilà pendant
longtemps voilà c'est très très
important parce que ça m'a permis de
d'avoir un personnel encadrant qui est à
l'écoute des patients et puis j'ai pu
trouver aussi d'autres patientes avec
moi qui ont su comprendre et c'est
vraiment
important cette solidarité cette écoute
cette bienveillance on peut avoir au
sein des trois arches et voilà ça vous a
aidé à sortir de l'isolement et le mot
important c'est la confiance ça vous a
aidé à reprendre confiance est-ce que
vous dites oui oui tout à fait ça a été
vraiment un vrai tremplin pour moi
revoir aussi une psychologue aussi ça
m'a permis aussi de libérer aussi ma
parole il y a des boules de parole aussi
donc j'ai pu bénéficier voilà j'ai fait
tout ce que j'avais pu voilà tout ce
dont j'avais besoin j'ai pu le faire et
ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup aidé j'ai fait
l'atelier pour le retour à l'emploi
alors que au moment où je l'ai fait je
n'étais vraiment pas en état de
reprendre le travail je me posais
beaucoup de questions sur la suite et si
vous êtes arrêté depuis décembre 2020
c'est bien ça
depuis début juin voilà donc j'en suis
très fière une très bonne nouvelle
Mathilde vous aviez une question
qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait de faire la
rencontre de Brigitte Macron
c'est toujours impressionnant
[Musique]
voilà je voulais faire passer ce message
là voilà
n'oubliez pas non plus c'est pas qu'un
cancer uniquement féminin ça peut aussi
toucher les hommes voilà
à faire passer et où est-ce que vous en
êtes dernière question aujourd'hui dans
votre parcours de soins justement et
bien justement comme ces métastatique et
même si j'ai de très bonnes nouvelles
puisque
voilà au niveau métastatique ben je
continue toujours les soins parce que
voilà pour le moment il y a pas assez de
recul
pour pour la suite donc on continue on
continue on continue voilà donc toujours
en soin toutes les trois semaines à
l'hôpital voilà on va y arriver
mais merci beaucoup Christelle Suchaud
pour ce témoignage je rappelle que vous
êtes habitante de la commune d'Andrésy
et vous êtes l'une des bénéficiaires de
cette structure les trois arches à
Poissy qui accompagnent justement les
personnes atteintes de cancer et aussi
leur proches et aussi les aidants autour
de ces thématiques merci faut pas
l'oublier merci d'avoir été avec nous
vous le disiez une grosse mobilisation
aussi en ce mois d'octobre à l'occasion
d'Octobre Rose et plusieurs initiatives
également qui sont au programme l'une
d'elles c'est la course des victoires
notamment avec un événement sportif et
solidaire qui est au profit de la
recherche contre le cancer 12 villes des
Yvelines participent à l'action au
programme et des marches et des courses
de 2,5 à 10 km des animations des
sensibilisations et des stands pour tout
savoir le site internet course des
victoires.fr les dons collectés seront
reversés à l'Institut Curie
[Musique]
la ville vous allez le voir dans un
instant avec cette interview express à
suivre la municipalité s'associe au
Cabaret du bout des prés pour une soirée
de mobilisation autour justement de ce
mois d'Octobre Rose ce sera le 18
octobre plusieurs animations sont au
menu et pour en parler Tony Bastian il
est le directeur du Cabaret du bout des
Prés et il le parle de cette initiative
à Mélanie poquet
[Musique]
le rendez-vous que nous proposons c'est
une manifestation festive mais surtout
informative sur le dépistage et la lutte
contre le cancer du sein
l'organisation a été faite par
l'ensemble du conseil municipal de la
mairie de Cernay-la-Ville et c'est
associé au Cabaret du bout des prés donc
tout en équipe administrative et son
équipe artistique
[Musique]
cette manifestation s'adresse à tout le
monde nous avons fait en sorte de
pouvoir mélanger l'information avec le
divertissement pour vous donner une idée
cette opération commencera à 18h30 avec
une marche de la mairie de
Cernay-la-Ville jusqu'au cabaret du bout
des prés une marche des femmes et cette
marche sera accompagnée des hommes et
des enfants avec des lampions rose qui
les accompagneront qui représenteront le
cœur des femmes voilà donc ça ça
concerne bien évidemment tout le monde
toute la population on a besoin de tous
simplement parce que l'équipe est en
majorité des femmes alors même si le
cancer du sein concerne les hommes et
les femmes c'est souvent plus souvent
les femmes qui sont concernées par cette
maladie et ça nous touche bien
évidemment encore plus puisque
le corps des des femmes et des danseuses
et leur outil de travail
et donc le cancer du sein est quelque
chose qui pourrait les concerner et que
nous avons envie de combattre
[Musique]
et puis toujours dans les villes
municipalités associations se mobilisent
en ce mois d'Octobre Rose
sensibilisation bien sûr au cancer du
sein le mois de sensibilisation cancer
du sein et l'encours dimanche c'est la
deuxième édition de marchand ensemble de
parcours un familial et un plus sportif
qui seront proposés à des paradises
depuis le parking de France Miniature tu
arrives de 5 euros au bénéfice de la
Ligue contre le cancer
[Musique]
et au programme de ce week-end également
Céline on le disait tout à l'heure c'est
la 14e édition du jour de la nuit c'est
même samedi à plus précisément le
lancement ce sera donc samedi 15 octobre
avec
plusieurs villes de France alors j'ai
pas forcément le bon texte voilà je suis
perdu dans mon texte mais en tout cas
c'est la première c'est l'édition et et
ce samedi on va y arriver et c'est la
14e édition merci pour l'oreillette
exactement donc si vous prévoyez de
sortir ce samedi 15 octobre ne vous
étonnez pas si vous retrouvez dans le
noir complet en vous promenant dans la
rue c'est la 14e édition de l'événement
le jour de la nuit organisé par
l'association Agir pour l'Environnement
le jour de la nuit c'est une grande
manifestation de sensibilisation à la
pollution lumineuse c'est national aussi
à la protection de la biodiversité
nocturne et à la beauté du ciel étoilé
au total il y a plus de 730 événements
dans toute la France entière ce weekend
alors plusieurs villes des Yvelines ont
choisi d'y participer en plus de
l'extinction de certaines lumière de la
ville Versailles par exemple organise
des observations des étoiles avec
télescope devant le château
Saint-Germain-en-Laye eux proposent une
sortie nocturne le long du rude buzeau
vous pourrez écouter les choses souris
et autres animaux de la nuit plaisir
propose plusieurs activités également la
projection d'un documentaire ou encore
l'observation du ciel la commune va
aussi éteindre les éclairages publics
autour de la mosaïque on écoute
Joséphine Coleman berger elle nous
explique les raisons de la participation
on est de plus en plus sensibilisé à les
uns et les autres tant au niveau je
dirais de la Biodiversité pour les
pollutions nocturnes mais également par
rapport au coût que cela induit et donc
aujourd'hui tous les je veux dire tout
tous les responsables politiques ou
administratifs on n'a pas la possibilité
de tout éteindre puisque les lumières
sont sous l'autorité enfin la compétence
en tout cas de 50 ans en Yvelines et
puis vous avez aussi des espaces qui
sont des espaces commerciaux et vous
avez aussi des espaces privés avec des
quartiers qui sont des quartiers
qui eux-mêmes gère leur éclairage
vous pouvez également retrouver le
programme ville par ville sur le site
jour de la nuit.fr
leur éclairage à nuit je sais pas si
vous dans vos communes respectives vous
avez déjà vu des éclairages éteins la
nuit du coup une certaine heure
quels sont justement les conséquences de
la pollution lumineuse
la pollution lumineuse est une des
principales causes de la disparition des
insectes puisqu'elle fragilise des
équilibres biologiques des écosystèmes
l'éclairage c'est aussi le deuxième
poste d'investissement dans les communes
de France métropolitaine autre chose
quand on lève les yeux au ciel
malheureusement on distingue plus qu'une
vingtaine d'étoiles mais vous avez
peut-être déjà fait l'expérience en
campagne loin des villes on peut en
observer jusqu'à plus d'un millier donc
voilà c'est c'est beaucoup plus
restreint et enfin l'Académie nationale
de médecine a également demandé à
classer l'exposition à la lumière de la
nuit dans la liste des agents
perturbateurs endocriniens responsable
par exemple des troubles du sommeil mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut même observer le
signal à l'oreillette voilà je le dis et
je suis franc dans cette émission des
fois on peut même distinguer l'ISS
lorsque le ciel est dégagé et c'est vrai
que quand on se trouve en ville bah
c'est un peu difficile effectivement
à la place des étoiles merci Céline en
tout cas pour ces explications sur le
jour de la nuit et donc le rendez-vous
c'est bien samedi même si je me suis
embrouillé au début de votre chronique
c'est bien c'est bien ça dans un instant
on va parler Gabriel on disait tout à
l'heure d'autres idées de sortie est-ce
que vous pouvez nous rappeler un petit
peu le menu qui nous attend dans
quelques instants je garde quelques
surprises mais on commencera par le
festival de la BD de Buc on parlera
également de château fort et de son de
son festival qui nous plonge dans le
moyen-âge donc c'est à découvrir non on
va prendre notre machine à remonter le
temps ce weekend à château fort on parle
de tout ça et ce sera après la page fort
[Musique]
cet aprèm on va avoir cet après-midi on
aura la la poursuite par équipe féminine
qui elle va on espère confirmer ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé hier mais
là ouais c'était un peu un peu un peu
difficile hier on va dire la douche
froide plus décevant parce que je pense
que la pression et la pression est forte
malgré malgré l'ambiance et et
l'accompagnement du public qui a
vraiment été présent hier avec beaucoup
de cheminée on s'aperçoit que oui ils
sont ils sont sous pression alors que on
leur demande pas grand chose on leur
demande juste de répéter ce qu'ils font
d'habitude oui on sent que le public
pousse ah oui dès que les Français sont
sur la sont sur la piste l'ambiance
l'ambiance
et devient devient euphorique et on sent
que vraiment les les Français sont un
public Chauvin on attendait beaucoup de
la vitesse par équipe hier soir au
niveau de l'équipe de France finalement
grosse déception il y a eu un faux
départ qui a tout changé c'est ça il
faut départ des Allemands Timmy
pas le commissaire faire le gilion
n'entends pas faire le commissaire faire
le faire le faux départ donc du coup il
fait un demi-tour à bloc et donc bah
voilà et c'est ce qui lui manque pour le
deuxième pour le deuxième départ il fait
4 dixièmes de plus 62e départ alors que
les suivants Ryan et Sébastien Vigier
Ryan est là laissez pas besoin de Vigier
eux améliorent leurs chronos de de la de
la qualification et c'est vrai que ben
on perd on perd l'accès à la médaille de
bronze pour 06 centièmes quoi c'est rien
quoi 06 10e ouais c'est ça c'est dixième
c'est vraiment des secondes rageant
rageant et rageant donc du coup on sent
que bah pour le reste là pour
aujourd'hui on va voir le kering
masculin et la vitesse individuelle
féminine on sent que nos coureurs on
l'arrache la France est dans une
obligation de médaille peut-être
aujourd'hui ça va être dur même
obligation médaille oui bien sûr parce
que tous les spectateurs et tout le
monde attend ça attendez attend d'avoir
des médailles mais c'est vrai que quand
on voit un glider qui revient qui
revient au sommet après après les années
difficiles en ayant lutin contre un
concert de la thyroïde et puis les
Hollandais qui sont qui sont dominateurs
depuis quelques années je leur souhaite
d'avoir une médaille ce soir mais ça va
être ça va être difficile alors on a les
épreuves de fond le scratch avec donova
Grondin là on a un très très bon très
très bon représentant et
donc là peut-être que ça peut ça pourra
le faire et c'est ce que je souhaite
mais sur la vitesse enfin sur le sprint
aujourd'hui
j'adorerais que Sébastien Vigier ramène
une médaille mais ça va être un ça va
être un gros gros un gros gros challenge
ce soir il y aura du spectacle forcément
il y a du Jarrier aussi dans ce vélo
donc de saint-quentin-en-y oui bien sûr
qu'il y a du spectacle comme dit comme
tous les jours tous les jours il va y
avoir des supers courses si n'hésitez
pas à venir parce que ce soit les restes
de la place vendredi il reste de la
place aussi donc c'est pas c'est venez
voir parce que l'ambiance est l'ambiance
mérite d'être d'être vu et ce soir pour
moi une des plus belles courses ça va
être la l'élimination féminine ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très très
particulier et on espère que Jade va
réussir à nous faire une belle une belle
prestation merci Yann dujariet vous avez
compris à Grégory la France doit
performer à dès ce soir remporté
quelques médailles pour lancer
parfaitement ces championnats du monde
ici à domicile
qui seront qui se dérouleront à
Versailles
du château de Versailles donc on aura un
super panorama pour pour ces JO toutes
les épreuves parce
qu'il y aura le
Jumpy pour une passionner comme moi ça
va être génial non le passionné de sport
que je suis vous êtes également on
l'attend aussi avec impatience parce que
dans une vie on va peut-être le vivre
qu'une fois est-ce qu'il y a un
engouement pour vous Gabriel Céline
autour de cet événement Gabriel c'est
une fierté d'avoir des épreuves juste à
côté de chez nous donc oui on a hâte de
les découvrir
mais pareil mais je pense que
l'équitation c'est ce qui retient le
plus mon attention aussi de tout de tous
les sports proposés
il y a plusieurs épreuves il y aura le
VTT sur la colline d'Élancourt le BMX
autour du Vélodrome national le golf au
Golf National de 50 ans en Yvelines on a
même appris que le marathon des JO
allait passer pour une partie en tout
cas dans les Yvelines donc il y aura de
quoi se mettre sous la dent pour pour
2024 on va revenir à ces championnats du
monde qui sont vus aussi comme un test
un peu grandeur nature pour ces Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 sur ces
Championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste 50 délégations étrangères sont
présentes parmi les athlètes venus du
monde entier il y a notamment le la
reste un petit pays du cyclisme et qui
est représenté par Fanny une habitante
des Yvelines rencontre signée Mickaël
Midor
des championnats du monde de l'année
dernière pour me remettre en situation
de l'ambiance de la motivation tout ce
qu'il faut Fanny se met en condition
cette cycliste mortazienne de 21 ans va
participer cette semaine au championnat
du monde de cyclisme sur piste 2022
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
spécialiste de la course au point la 13e
mondiale va courir sous les couleurs du
Laos un choix de cœur mon
arrière-grand-mère est là au ciel et
elle est venue vivre en France après et
j'ai beaucoup d'attaches pour la famille
et je voulais représenter les couleurs
de mes origines avec le Laos depuis
officiellement deux ans fanny a déjà
participé à plusieurs compétitions dont
les championnats asiatiques en juin
dernier une carrière internationale qui
se fait loin de l'équipe de France je
n'ai jamais été contacté par l'équipe de
France et comme j'arrivais à un âge où
il fallait que je décide vraiment je
voulais faire du haut niveau ou pas j'ai
fait le choix de représenter Laos lors
de ces Championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste 2022 Fanny ne se sentira pas
dépaysés la jeune athlète s'entraîne
régulièrement sur les créneaux tout
public dans la structure située à
quelques kilomètres de chez elle ici la
sportive à ses repères je pense que
c'est un légère avantage par rapport à
d'autres nations qui ne l'ont jamais vu
ou moins vu c'est vrai que moi je
m'entraîne quasiment tous les jours ici
donc oui je pense que ça peut être un
avantage par rapport à certaines
personnes pendant ce rendez-vous est
Vinois la piste selon représentante de
son pays partagera son box avec l'équipe
d'Algérie à domicile à l'oracle de
briller devant son public en finissant
le plus haut possible sa course est
programmée ce dimanche 16 octobre pour
le moment c'est comme si c'était encore
dans une semaine et faut pas trop y
penser pour pas stresser après ces
championnats du monde Fanny encore des
rêves plein la tête la tête de haut
niveau veut viser le titre JO de Los
Angeles en 2028 et également une
participation aux Jeux olympiques de
Paris en 2024 un événement qui se
déroulera dans un vélo Drôme qu'elle
connaît si bien
[Musique]
il est venu le temps non pas des
cathédrales dans cette émission même
s'il sera question de Moyen-Âge dans un
instant mais de la première chronique en
plateau sur le plateau de TV 78 de
Gabriel Gontier ça va pas trop de
pression pour pour cette première
chronique vous allez nous parler des
idées de sortie du weekend en tout cas à
votre sélection des idées de sortie du
week-end et vous commencez par le
festival de la BD de buxe un rendez-vous
classique chaque année à l'automne et ça
revient pour une 29e édition tout à fait
Grégory cette année encore le festival
accueille une cinquantaine d'auteurs
adultes jeunesse mais aussi français et
internationaux au programme du week-end
des dédicaces des rencontres avec les
auteurs des expositions et des
animations une fois encore les petits et
grands vont pouvoir retrouver leur
personnage préféré oui cette année on
retrouve Spirou les profs Yakari et bien
d'autres de quoi faire le bonheur des
passionnés de BD je vous en avez des
préférés peut-être de BD
je vous pose pas la question ce que vous
aviez déjà donné quelques éléments de
réponse mardi dans le 7 8 mais c'est
Mathilde si vous avez posé la question
donc on va lui poser la question
le personnage préféré alors moi c'est
une BD peu connue en fait ça s'appelle
Julie Clerc Cécile c'est une BD belge et
voilà c'est une BD peu connu mais que
j'adorais lire quand j'étais plus jeune
c'est l'histoire de trois jeunes femmes
donc la fête de la BD ça se passe ce
weekend du côté de Buc alors c'est tout
aussi immersif c'est à château fort
cette fois-ci avec aussi un rendez-vous
traditionnel c'est la foire médiévale
c'est ce weekend oui complètement
traditionnel on peut le dire c'est la
36e édition de la foire de château fort
en immersion les visiteurs seront
projetés des siècles en arrière pour
retrouver l'ambiance du Moyen-Âge avec
des décors de rue des activités des
moyens de se restaurer aussi à la
manière de l'époque alors prévoyez votre
meilleur costume Grégory si vous comptez
y aller ce week-end ça devrait passer
peut-être ça non mais costume plutôt
médiéval plutôt médiéval avec peut-être
une armure à prévoir pour cette foire
médiévale pour les plus téméraires c'est
pas forcément mon cas il y a le musée
Maurice Denis qui propose une Murder
Party c'est samedi soir de quoi
sera-t-il question c'est ça le musée
vous propose d'enfiler cette fois votre
casquette de détective pour résoudre
tenez-vous bien une enquête criminelle
l'Escape Game vous plonge alors dans une
soirée tragique des années 1875 ou
l'autre de la soirée Charles bondoua va
subitement être assassiné et ça ça se
passe au sein même du musée c'est ça
c'est ce qui rend l'expérience assez
impressionnante et immersive le jeu
prend place au sein même des salles
d'exposition dans un décor aménagé pour
l'occasion est-ce que c'est accessible à
tous alors pour vous pas de souci
Grégory en revanche c'est déconseillé
pour les moins de 15 ans un autre
événement à retenir peut-être ce
week-end pour terminer oui dans le cadre
de la Semaine du Goût samedi et dimanche
un parcours du goût est organisé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il est ouvert au
grand public le salon donne lieu à un
concours culinaire qui est destiné à des
jeunes pris en charge dans le cadre de
la PJJ alors la PJJ c'est la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse l'objectif
Grégory ici c'est de favoriser
l'insertion de ces jeunes à l'occasion
de des événements d'ailleurs le garde
des sceaux et ce soir ce jeudi soir dans
les Yvelines tout à fait le ministre de
la Justice Eric Dupont-Moretti seront ce
soir à Versailles pour plus signé par
non plusieurs conventions notamment une
avec le CFA Médéric et la maison Ladurée
pour prévoir l'accueil des jeunes de la
PGJ en stage et en contrat
d'apprentissage
festival de la BD semaine du groupe
hôtel faites votre choix Mathilde c'est
compliqué là tous les choix sont assez
tentants
au sein de la rédaction si je puis dire
tout le monde en a parlé cet après-midi
on a déjà des expériences et c'est vrai
que
la foire médiévale peut-être ce weekend
et du côté de Châteaufort merci Gabriel
c'est très bien merci beaucoup pour pour
ces idées de sortie alors il y a une
autre idée de sortie aussi qu'on a
sélectionné pour vous et ça se passe du
côté de Versailles on peut joindre
l'utile et aussi au solidaire voilà
cette idée de consiste un concert pour
l'Ukraine alors plus précisément même
pour les familles ukrainiennes réfugiées
en France ça se passe dimanche du côté
de la cathédrale Saint-Louis de
Versailles le début du concert est fixé
à 15h et s'est organisé par le Lion's
club de la région de Versailles à
l'affiche la chorale La corinie Francis
Rodier qui est à l'orgue et également
Georges Schmitt qui était à la flûte de
Pan genre je Schmitt qui était avec nous
au début de cette édition qui a vous a
parlé de ça c'est flûte aussi qu'il
confectionne lui-même et donc vous êtes
avec nous justement pour nous parler
plus précisément cette fois-ci de ce
concert alors pour vous représenter
George Schmitt 16 albums à votre actif
plus de 4 millions de disques vendus
dans le monde 11 disques d'or pourquoi
avoir accepté d'être à l'affiche de ce
concert pourquoi être de ce concert
dimanche à Versailles pourquoi c'était
important pour vous
c'est très important parce que je suis
né à Alger moi je suis d'une famille
alsacienne mais grands-parents déjà en
1870 ont été chassés de l'Alsace et pour
pas devenir allemand et donc c'est
pourquoi je suis né en Algérie et
dans les années 60 fin des années 61
vous entendez oui on vous entend
toujours
et en 61 on est parti en catastrophe
d'Alger où je suis né donc et quand j'ai
vu ces images enfin la télévision
l'exode des
[Musique]
Ukrainiens moi
faire rappeler mon enfance où j'avais 14
ans on est parti en catastrophe voilà
tout ça je me suis dit moi mon petit
niveau de musicien il faut que je fasse
quelque chose plus de 60 000 il y a plus
de 60 000 Ukrainiens qui sont arrivés en
France d'après le gouvernement entre
février septembre 2022 en plus de ça on
voit que le conflit reprend de l'ampleur
en Ukraine avec des bombardements aussi
qui se font de plus en plus présents en
Ukraine c'est important de pas les
oublier les Ukrainiens de ne pas oublier
exactement parce que je me rends compte
qu'il y a actuellement
baisse l'intérêt je pense pour ces
réfugiés Ukrainiens pas que je veux
absolument faire quelque chose là on a
décidé j'ai eu étant moi-même président
du Lion's Club des Essarts-le-Roi j'ai
contacté les Lions Club de Yvelines et
tout le monde a répondu présent et
il y a en tout 22 clubs qui ont accepté
de participer avec moi dans cette action
et ça j'en suis tellement heureux de
monde a répondu présent malheureusement
des Lyons club sur sur la programmation
même de ce concert vous serez aux côtés
de Francis Rodier à lorgue est-ce que
vous avez l'habitude de jouer ensemble
se fait des années on fait des tournées
ensemble voilà on a fait énormément
énormément de concerts mais je pensais
se rudié c'est vraiment un ami il est
titulaire des grandes ordres de l'église
Sainte Jeanne d'Arc de Versailles et
lui-même moi j'habite Les
Clayes-sous-Bois et lui habite
Villepreux donc on est on est voisins
et ce sera quel répertoire qui sera
proposé pour ce concert dimanche il y a
du répertoire
classique d'un Lidl bac mais j'ai eu le
bonheur moi de toute ma carrière de de
travailler avec Ennio Morricone j'ai mis
une pièce d'animaux école au programme
il y a des pièces de variété entre
guillemets mais puis il y a des champs
Ukrainiens également il y a le cœur
ukrainien et il se trouve qu'il y a eu
entre temps que réfugiés ukrainien
musicien on leur a demandé de participer
à cette action il faut savoir que tout
le monde vient absolument bénévolement
pas aucune personne n'est rémunéré on a
décidé de faire 100% la recette sera
reversée réfugiés ukrainien et
effectivement à vos côtés il y aura le
cœur à Corini qui est la chorale
ukrainienne de 50 ans en Yvelines qui
proposera des champs traditionnels
Ukrainiens le prix déplacés et de 20
euros et
remercier du coup pour pour l'accueil
des réfugiés en France c'est ça
parce que je ne veux surtout pas que ce
soit ça part quelque part mais là
vraiment je
étant moi-même Lyon club quand on fait
un organisme une action un euro gagné
c'est un euro
et voilà il y a une billeterie alors à
l'entrée oui on va pouvoir peut-être
afficher le lien sur helloasso.com c'est
ça
peut réserver sur et excusez-moi j'ai
presque plus de voix parce que j'ai
répété toute la journée
et ça tire beaucoup sur les cordes
vocales mais voilà donc il suffit
d'aller sur le sur hello à so.com on
tape Lion's Club de noisy-bayon on
retrouve facilement le lien normalement
pour pour ce concert et pour ceux qui
sont un petit peu aussi cette façon de
régler et bien il y a une billetterie à
l'entrée de la
merci beaucoup Georges Schmid d'avoir
été avec nous merci
très ami avec Hugues Aufray un vieil ami
il habite près de chez moi et j'ai
enregistré les plus belles chansons du
coffret cet album est donc avec flûte de
Pan orchestre et coeur et une chorale
d'enfants cet album sortira en janvier
2023 merci pour cette annonce on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler bien sûr sur TV
78 je rappelle d'ailleurs à noter les
spectateurs qui peuvent retrouver votre
portrait on vous avait suivi en 2017 et
je le disais vous avez un parcours
incroyable un seul album 4 millions de
disques vendus et 11 disques d'or à
votre actif merci encore d'avoir été
avec nous et je rappelle donc les
informations pour ce concert c'est
dimanche en la cathédrale Saint-Louis à
Versailles le début du concert est à 15h
cet organisé je le disais par le Lion's
club de la région de Versailles et pour
prendre votre place on vous le rappelle
rendez-vous sur le site eloasso.com
avant de vous quitter dernier coup d’œil
à la météo
[Musique]
ces nuageux malheureusement dans la
matinée de vendredi dans toutes les
Yvelines côté température 15 degrés à
Versailles Rambouillet ou dans ces 14
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie pour
l'après-midi ça s'arrange ou ça empire
selon vous habitez de la pluie à Houdan
et Rambouillet où il fera respectivement
16 et 15 degrés ça devrait rester
nuageux à Versailles avec 15 degrés il y
aura quelques éclaircies à
Mantes-la-Jolie ce vendredi 14 octobre
nous fêterons les justes on va regarder
également ce qui va se passer ce
week-end en tout cas les prévisions
annoncées ils devraient pleuvoir une
nouvelle fois sur la commune de
Rambouillet des éclaircies sur le reste
des Yvelines le thermomètre grimpera à
18 et 19 degrés et malheureusement
dimanche il devrait pleuvoir dans tout
le département ça fait un peu grise mine
en plateau voilà sans mauvais jeu de
mots elle sera un petit peu plus frais
également dans les températures avec
justement des températures entre 16 et
19 degrés
voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci
beaucoup Gabriel merci Céline merci
Mathilde c'était un plaisir d'être avec
vous sur ces quasi 50 minutes
d'émissions le 7 8 qui revient lundi
avec toujours plus et d'actualité
d'idées de sortie d'info pratique et
d'ici là bien sûr passer un excellent
weekend sur TV 78
[Musique]